[Music]
you just can't be out here just doing a
mix tape though you thinking from a
reckless standpoint now but looks you
have you nothing something you do got to
be grown up and people got to see it and
it ain't drinking and then smoking
that's young people do you got to make
that turn so I feel like I gotta think
about what it is I want to do I guess
since it's my life I got to figure it
out you got to decide if that's what you
want to do now you don't want to really
go in that direction you like Mara we'll
make some drip sauce records and just
continue to keep off and being freshers
on this and that's cool too that's what
we do but I don't think that I don't
think that's when you figure out this
music thing let me know when it comes a
family you gotta be able to call each
other out Germania what I'm capable of
doing I know what I'm capable of doing
and with that Jermaine gets a little
frustrated cuz he's like he wants me to
continue wants me to do more
[Music]
you